Fabio Ognibeni always enjoys working with
wood -- particularly if it has a nice texture.
"The wood is smooth and even.
That's just the right kind for making musical
instruments."
But a major windstorm on October 29 knocked
down almost all of the trees here in Val di
Fiemme.
"The next day, I felt like a friend had died."
The high winds blew down trees across entire
mountainsides.
"It sounded like gunshots, or small explosions.
When the wind knocks down an entire tree,
it makes an awful lot of noise.
It's like the sound of a million branches
breaking."
Fabio has been coming to this area for 13
years to find just the right kind of wood.
For centuries, the forest has provided wood
for violins, guitars, and pianos.
The wood gives the instruments an excellent
sound and resonance.
But now, Fabio is trying to save what he can.
"This trunk has a good diameter, and a good
texture.
But this crack right here shows that the tree
split when it was knocked over -- so I can't
use it."
Fabio wants to save as much wood as he can
before it's ruined by bark-beetles and other
pests.
"I love this kind of work, and I love these
trees.
This is my passion."
The wood is processed at Fabio's small factory
down in the valley.
This is where mountain spruce is converted
into tone-wood and resonance-wood.
Fabio's customers include a number of major
companies that produce musical instruments.
This finely cut tone-wood will be used to
make violins.
It's been sorted by age and quality.
More than 300 years ago, Antonio Stradivari
crafted his violins from wood similar to this.
But right now, Fabio is trying to recover
as much wood as he normally does in four years
-- and it's going to cost a lot of money to
store it.
So he's asked customers and private clients
to pay € 300 in advance per tree trunk -- to
cover storage costs.
That's why he's choosing only the best wood
right now.
"I've got to examine every trunk carefully
to determine which piece of wood would be
best for each instrument -- and how many pieces
can I get out of a trunk."
Only top-quality wood will be processed.
Fabio keeps a close watch on all of the tree-trunks
– even in the sawmill.
Here, the trunks are pre-cut along the grain.
This wood will be used to make soundboards
for pianos.
Sawmill Owner Franco Seber is sorry that so
many trees were lost in the windstorm.
"It took those trees 120 years to grow to
maturity -- and then the storm ruined everything.
It's sad -- and now it'll take another 120
years for the forest to grow back."
Customers who appreciate Fabio's skill and
experience will support him during these tough
times.
"Fabio has an extremely important job: he's
the only one who can find this kind of high-quality
wood.
Violin makers like me couldn't do it.
But we're all part of the process of creating
a musical instrument, so we have to trust
each other."
Every step of that process must be spot on,
as Fabio's tone-wood is made into a violin.
"I'm happy when the client is pleased with
the instrument.
The manufacturers and the musicians deserve
a lot of credit, too -- but people seem to
forget that it's my wood that makes the instrument."
Fabio Ognibeni's customers certainly haven't
forgotten.
And for the time being, he'll continue to
salvage as much wood as he can from the Val
di Fiemme site -- so that he can keep providing
top-quality material for world-class musical
instruments.